SUBJECT: So I'm interested
in the kinds of ideas
that dissolve boundaries, that
remind us of what is possible,
that encourage us to
think differently,
to probe at the
adjacent possible.
There's great line that says,
once a mind is stretched
by a new idea, it
will never return
to its original position.
The kind of things that
make us question everything.
And Tom Robbins has
a great description.
He says a cyclone
of unorthodox ideas
that will raise every every,
any mind out of its cognitive
Kansas.
In other words, we
are like Dorothy,
and we crave the
kind of whirlwind
of ideas that will transport us,
transfigurate us, and land us
in Oz, a place where there is
room for mystery, a place where
there's room for
juxtaposition and surrealism,
a reenchanted world, again,
where everything is possible.
That's what powerful ideas do.
They are inceptions.
They are planted in there
and transform us from within.
And now all of us are
broadcasters, right?
Programmers.
We don't just passively take in.
We produce and publish.
And so it's up to us to
get the kind of ideas
out of into the world that
will spread mimetically
and that will collectively
upgrade mankind.
It's our responsibility, as the
co-authors of the memespace,
to tell great stories, to
enliven the imagination,
to stretch our brains
beyond the cognitive Kansas.
This should be our anthem.
This is our responsibility.